alright we're live welcome guys another
chat super excited to be here with you
and and a friend of the channel second
time on Julie and Marian welcome aboard
Yankee thank you ah Julian is doing a
blog post on sleep for entrepreneurs and
wanted my input and advice and I said
hey instead of just doing this over
email let's do it as a as a hangout
let's get some chat going let's do it on
video and hopefully others can benefit
from it as well so this is interesting
because I haven't covered it that much
on my channel I think I've got no right
video this would be fun so maybe quick
intro for my audience who you are what
you're all about and then dive into the
questions let's do it absolutely so my
name is Julian Marion I want to dance
and fitness studio Kevin you know on the
dance studio I'm involved but I don't
always teach a lot of the classes i also
have ok you can call a successful
podcast in the business category called
the path to unlimited and it's all about
just lifting the lid of people's life to
see better just removing all those
self-imposed limitations or limitations
that the hashtag little man trying to
put on them there you go the little men
should have put on them and just
allowing them to just you know see
bigger by bringing people like you know
Evan on board and and just you know
sharing their stories and they give an
action plan something you can actually
follow so you can get results because
you know i'm all about just action and
less about talk and this month of work
on the project called sleep sumo calm
and it's all about helping entrepreneurs
sleep better because i know you know
entrepreneurs like we push so hard
because we know that the more after we
put in the more reward we get so we just
like go to two three four in the morning
we've been up some time since 5am and we
don't see how much time actually we're
spending awake and not enough time
sleeping and what happened is you go to
those 55 days or somesuch think we have
five six days of almost no sleep and
then you crash really hard and when you
crash with your heart what happen is you
start to get depressed because maybe
nice you don't see the momentum anymore
because you're tired everything seems to
be to just suck like the email rejection
that you're getting now you just amplify
maybe even more versus hey it's happened
i'm just really tired i have my sleep
I can see that well I only have about
eight hours like in four days you know
that's the reason so anyway so that's
what the podcast pressure limit is about
and the project sleep sumo is about all
right little hit me up question let's go
with it all right so simple question
what time do you wake up wake up but um
so I usually go to sleep around midnight
and i usually wake up around
seven-thirty 7 730 somewhere in there um
that's a typical day it's throwing
around every now and then but that's
that's kind of typical for me ok so as
an entrepreneur right with like a crazy
schedule because I know you're such a
schedule like you have your set days on
when you produce episodes when you do
your you know public appearances right
like with you know blab and just go on
other peoples podcast it's like how do
you manage all that how'd you manage to
really get enough sleep with all that
crazy schedule yeah and I have an added
thing where I have a really weak from
you immune system like if I don't sleep
seven hours consistently at least I get
sick if I go two days in a row a bad
sleep I'm sick I guess it's you got a
phone call there bro thank God it's
supposed to be on mute yeah I get sick
like and for people who've been watching
my channel there's a lot of videos where
I'm sick and it's often because of like
either lack of sleep or just you know at
the dance studio there's always lots of
people and you know catch viruses um so
I need sleep if I if I don't get sleep
one night the next night has to be solid
or I know I'm gonna be up so how do you
ensure that you get that you get your
seven hours then yeah so a couple couple
things I think some of them are basics
that you probably heard before you know
try to keep to the same time try not to
eat like a heavy meal before going to
sleep because at least I keats me out
I'm super sensitive to light so I I have
a mask on that that you know like if I
travel I forget my mask i'm having
terrible sleep but some other things
that may be a little different than what
most people are doing um one we have no
electronics in the
room so there's no cell phone in bedroom
was no iPad in the bedroom is there's
nothing with a light you know they could
people stay up and read that like blue
screen and that just keeps you awake and
so our phones are plugged in outside the
room and so my wife has an alarm in the
morning she is gonna get up out of bed
to go turn it off this is nothing
electronic in the room so that one house
because before we're kind of sitting in
bed next to each other before we pass
out and i think one it also kind of
gives you a little more connection
because there's there's nothing to read
so you talking about talking to your
wife before going to bed haha but i
think you know you get so distracted by
emails and news and stuff so so no
electronics in the room and that's
that's helped both of us I think sleep
um too is when i get an idea i go and
take care of it so i'll get out of bed
sometimes you go to bed with with an
idea like ah you know I got a great idea
for Julian's dance studio man and then
and then you lie in bed trying to forget
it and in you know wrestling with it and
for me it'll keep me up all night and
I'm going to worry that I'm going to
forget it because I don't have a great
memory if I don't write it down it's
gone and so I will get up and send that
email off to Julian the Talmud about
what do you need to do for his name
studio or whoever it is and then it's
like it's released because otherwise it
stays with me and I have a terrible
sleep and so I'm not afraid to get up
and out to solve whatever is kind of
that that monkey in my head that need to
release it um having a routine to help
you wind down I find super helpful so
just like you know when you're a kid you
have you have a routine that your
parents give you write like you have a
bath and you brush your teeth and you
get a bedtime story and like you get
used to that yeah routine and then that
helps you like oh your body sets a
shutdown right and then we kind of lose
a lot of that when we get into adulthood
and it's it's I used to find it really
hard like I come back from my salsa
studio after a great night and I don't
be wired like talking to people like I
just can't go to sleep right away sorry
to create a schedule a little routine to
to decompress a little bit and so
whatever it is for you it's great for me
we start by I light a candle so we have
a candle since we don't have electronics
in the room we also turn off the lights
so light a candle that's on my wife side
and that's how I start you know I'll
then open up the bed and like make space
for both of us and then go and like
brush my teeth and just read some news
to like decompress and get my mind off
business um you know floss wash my face
go to bed do some cuddling and then go
to sleep and so it's like the same thing
every night and then as soon as I go to
the bedroom to turn on the candles I've
start windows compressing winding down
and then I start getting tired and after
like the 15 20 minutes ticking to do
everything else and I'm ready to go to
sleep so having that kind of routine
whatever it is for you I find helps so
yeah okay I got a couple more but we can
interrupt go no I wanted to that thing
doesn't make soap okay here echo echo
how's that much better all right there
we go so I just want it Before we jump
in before we move on you talked about
this a couple things where he talked
about just like no electronics in a room
right and I know for a lot of people
right away I know what they say right
what my phone is my alarm right so
that's why I need my phone my phone is
my alarm so you say you don't have any
in the room so is it like totally
outside of your room that you guys
pretty much like outside the door that's
where it's plugged or do you have it you
know maybe in the living room that's
where all the phones are plugged the cow
what is the process that you have you
guys have there yeah so I'm a little off
the wall convert the most people where I
don't even use a phone like I don't have
a cell phone with a number i use it more
as a tablet than a phone um and I don't
use an alarm either but my wife does and
she's attached to her phone it sits
outside of our bedroom so there's a is a
little kind of sitting area outside of
her bedroom and that's where she plugs
it in and it forces her to get up and
out of bed to turn off the alarm which
prevents the you used to be next to her
and like snooze snooze things
don't gets too I don't get people who
snooze you know I realize that people do
it for me was like I'll are my mom I set
an alarm to get up not just news for 20
minutes and then get up but she is the
snoozer but now she can't cuz that alarm
is like blaring and it gets louder every
time as it goes she's got to get up and
out of bed and it's you know she's up so
you're much more likely to stay up I
know there's some there's some alarms
that like I found this one on
Kickstarter that it sits on your desk
and then it bounces around the room you
gotta like get up and chase it in case
they already up so yeah so so falling
asleep to candlelight as opposed to like
a big overhead light and not having like
the TV on or phone on or iPad or
anything on it's just we find it easier
at least to fall asleep so kind of the
more of a general question out to the
karaoke know our audience in you know
some that are listening to us right now
why do you think that entrepreneurs
sacrifice sleep over work I think a lot
of law has to get done you know like
entrepreneurs have insane amounts of
work you're you're especially in the
early days you're you're the CEO to the
janitor this like nobody cares more than
you you may not have the budget to be
able to delegate to somebody else or you
may suck at delegating and feel like
you're the only one who has the skills
to be able to do whatever project you
can work is never done as an
entrepreneur like there's always
something there's only always want to
grow you always you either putting out a
fire that has to get done or you've got
this great new vision of what you want
to do and you want to get it done like
your inbox is never empty there's always
something happening and so there's
always that pressure especially if it's
a financial one where it's really on in
your business before you're able to
fully support yourself you feel like if
I don't get this done I could be out of
a business in six months and have to go
get a job again so you're hustling and
fighting for that and and people know
you know rationally logically that I
can't keep doing this because I'm going
to get sick and I'm going to burn out
and I'm going to crash whatever that's a
hard argument when you're feeling the
crunch and feeling the pain to kind of
drive through and push so I do you think
we can how do you think we can I
guarantee that that we don't do that
right that we don't just keep on pushing
keep on pushing keep on pushing it
because we think like one more one more
one more right like so what do you think
we can do to just you know not get there
um so for me there's two sides of that
coin one is work because work has to get
done and I think for that you need to
set boundaries for yourself and schedule
it in like if you're married or you know
you have a girlfriend boyfriend whatever
make make time with them just as
important as time in your business
otherwise that relationships not going
to last right so I put things in my
calendar right time with Nina so that is
an appointment that I don't let run over
because otherwise a lot of your business
can bleed into your personal time and so
you need to set some kind of boundary on
it the exception that I make is what I'm
in flow like there are times when you
are just feeling it not not because you
got to like do something that's going to
have a minimal impact but just like
you're in the zone you're flowing this
then it's not every day when you're in
that zone when I'm there I try to stay
there as long as I can i push everything
off as long as I can until I feel like
I'm not in flow anymore and i feel i
feel it's super important to do that so
I don't have an alarm in the morning my
wife has hers but if if I'm really
feeling something I will stay up until
however late like till my body crashes
and then I'll sleep in the next day and
I never book stuff in the morning my
mornings are never booked I do I have a
routine that I usually go through and
part of that is checking in my social
media feeds and responding people on
YouTube and stuff that I do on a daily
basis but i never have a meeting booked
before noon is it because you want you
to like just work on on other stuff or
is it because you just want to have like
your full routine morning routine it's a
combination of 1 i'm not a morning
person in general so if I'm meeting
people I'd rather meet them later than
in the morning and two it's a buffer you
know so as an example on tues
it was my book writing day I'm writing a
book um and it was a 16-hour day for me
I started in the i started with to
YouTube Hangouts with Tim Schmoyer who
has a popular YouTube channel to help
entrepreneurs video entrepreneurs and
then I went in the full book writing
mode and was 12 straight hours of book
writing with only bathroom breaks uh my
wife came home and she's like have you
eaten like I haven't eaten and so she
like spoon fed me like no seriously like
like I don't time I gotta do this you
know so she's like taking a fork of the
sausage and putting it in my mouth like
like I'm a baby um but I mean it's
awesome that have a supportive wife and
I'm not doing that every day or the word
I would you know obviously put a strain
on our relationship and and my health
but I was in the zone like if I stepped
out from that and then tried to step
back into it would take me like an hour
two hours just to get back to where I
was and I may not even get to that
mental zone of where I was at that time
and so when that happens when I'm really
feeling in the zone on something then I
try to stay there as long as possible
and that could mean the next day I sleep
in right I could sleep in till 10 and
i'll miss ain't strings on youtube
comments and i'll push that to the next
day because the stuff that you create
when you're in the zone is way more
important than the stuff in your regular
daily agenda so i'll push meetings i'll
push everything off if I have that
feeling that I'm in no I mean fire yeah
it's important yeah it is and too many
people cut that off like you may have
been in the zone on something really
feeling it and then you're forced to
leave it and then you come back and it's
not complete and you don't know how to
complete in the energy is gone and it's
easy to trick yourself like I'm really
in the flow answering these emails you
know it's like that's not what we're
talking about right like it big picture
ideas that's really gonna catapult your
business forward that's that's what I'm
talkin to buddy you know like don't lie
to yourself you know when something is
really important and you're feeling it
and so I'll push off like I'll forget to
eat I'll forget yeah you just go every
then right and I'll push through I won't
even realize that I'm tired right
because i'm just so i didn't realize
that was 12 straight hours without
looking up and doing anything else um me
my wife came home she has a normal
nine-to-five job it's like wow it's
already five thirty what where did it go
I'm just locked in and so when I'm there
I try to stay there um and I wish I
could say I'm locked in every day but
I'm not but but whatever you do it I
think even a Beyonce talk about that
when she uh oh the regular coke I got
you haha awesome so now I'm talk about
Beyonce sometime acute he was sharing
that ritek sometimes she would go if you
forget right she just like remember
because her body starts to get slightly
dizzy Wright he says you back when I get
dizzy oh wow I haven't eaten you know
like it's like he says like five six
o'clock and i just ate breakfast you
know i didn't eat lunch i was just like
so into just creating my music in my art
that I forget so how sad for you so you
know like this this this is new
generation of entrepreneurs that I feel
like sometimes once you make
entrepreneurs feel guilty if they sleep
right there talking about twenty-four
seven No Limit no sleep no break 365
don't sleep get it done right and I feel
so many entrepreneurs trying to just do
that because they feel guilty for
sleeping because of waiting find sleep
he's working right so so how can we help
like entrepreneurs kind of just like
break through that of like hey it's okay
to sleep in the Hat you know has like no
sleep 365 24 7 is not as my reality is
not real that you can just like go like
that yeah I think it's important to you
know pick your mentors wisely and and
pick what you like from different people
so when you talk about hustle and no
sleep in 24 7 you know people that come
to mind for me would be like a mark
cuban gary vaynerchuk guys who like
hustle is their mantra and that's all
they say is like work harder and and
then I look at well do I want their life
and the life works for them but it
doesn't work for me like you can you can
see behind the scenes of Gary Vee and
how is basically travel
Lane in meetings and working all day
every day and take some breaks in the
weekends but that works for him you know
and seeing his kids every now and then
works for him and and for me it's not
the life that I want and so I work hard
when I'm working and then I also need to
find time to work on my relationship and
be with my wife and my son and you know
my family and so I think you just have
to find and maybe that limits me like
maybe that limits how much I can grow my
business right that that's that's the
downside like every hour i'm spending
with my wife i'm not spending with my
business that it could be something
game-changing that could really catapult
or word and so that's that's the
sacrifice that I'm willing to make
because I wouldn't feel fulfilled as a
human being if I didn't have my
relationship so I think it just it's an
individual thing some people value
family more some people value their
business more you got to find where that
balances for you and and live it and and
be happy with yeah that's going to limit
my success as an entrepreneur but it
contributes to my success as a as a
family member and a human being so you
say pretty much so it's a quick recap
what you said to make a clear choice on
on who decide to to follow as a mentor
right like if this guy's life doesn't
match my vision of success that I'm not
going to follow that right that that
thing that's one that you talked about
too is also looking more as your but you
look at more the life you want to live
and have that being you know matching
your business versus I want to get into
this business but then you're not
willing to sec sacrifice right the the
hours with your family the hours with
your kids you know to get there and
maybe third is also the perspective that
you have on all limitations to some
extent right like what do you you feel
like if I sacrifice hours to work on my
business does that mean that I'm not
going to be successful you know versus
not a conscious decision that I have to
Spence how my family because what is the
point of having a successful business
but at home I'm losing right I'm losing
at home but I'm winning in my business
because you get it home in and you see
so many successful entrepreneurs that
have that
right with a like so successful in
business but then they go home and is is
the constant just like struggle because
you're considered a workaholic so
question to you now would you consider
yourself a workaholic or not or you want
consider you a workaholic or not um it's
interesting it's like I feel like the
term is as a negative connotation I
think for me my default would often be
to work you know like I don't have a
need you know for example my wife loves
spending time with friends right like
when she doesn't spend time with friends
she feels depleted uh for me man you
know like I love my friends happy to
hang out with them but if I haven't seen
them for a month or two whatever it's
like I just kicked back into it when I
see them again it's not a big need for
me and so my default would be to work if
I had if I had time off with nobody
around me like my wife goes on vacation
or something without me I would work I
wouldn't be partying it up or you know
doing other things I would work I love
my work like for me work is not work
most of the stuff this still some work
that's work against but for the most
part I'm doing things that I genuinely
enjoy enjoy doing and so I would just
want to do more of the stuff that I
enjoy doing so if I don't schedule
something in then my work will bleed
into my calendar and I think that's what
that's the creep that a lot of people
feel like they don't block off their
personal time just like they would block
off a business meeting you know if you
have a business meeting with somebody
you're going to show up because you
committed the first you're going to show
up but you don't commit to your wife
that you're going to show up for dinner
on Thursday night or whatever right so
like I put that into my calendar and I
show up um and so heavily that's a Colin
daylight I'm message for you when you
put everything together right you have a
huge master calendar I guess then we put
everything on their business personal
and all that stuff on there yeah right
okay awesome because I think that's like
you said us this a huge thing that a lot
of entrepreneurs
don't have where you have your business
schedule but then you don't plug in the
personal because you you know you try to
split them as much as as much as
possible so I think just from what the
conversation we're having I think that's
a huge one that I'm hear from you you
know because that allows you to really
spend more time with your family and
know when you kind of shut off but you
don't shut off if you're in the flow
because at that point this is when you
create gold and you want to push as hard
as you can there you need to get at
least your seven hours because if you
don't get seven hours for extended
period of time you don't feel good the
next day you take the cell phone out
because you want to keep electronics in
a room the TVs no no light you have a
candle no alarm wife is here what is
fizzy alarm the stomach stead now that
last question about that in terms of
intake right like dinnertime are you
conscious about what you eat before
going to bed or or not at all um I have
been more recently we've been on da we
came back from a cruise to Puerto Rico
and then went around and I came back as
the heaviest i've ever been that was two
hundred and six and a half pounds which
is heaviest for me I'm 62 in my life and
I came back as okay we're gonna do a
30-day YouTube challenge and we're going
to record our hour fitness and our
health and our diet and that's going to
start being released I believe this
weekend on the channel now I'm 189 and a
half so from 206 to 189 a lot through
diet and and it's helped me one in terms
of not getting sick but then also
sleeping better at night um it's
basically at night trying not to eat too
much that kind of would upset my stomach
or something that needs to digest so if
I'm eating anything it might be like a
drink or like a smoothie or something
that's easier to digest yeah um I just
find if I eat a big meal that just keeps
me awake my stomach is grumbling and
like I just can't fall asleep and so
that's been a while deal like i haven't
eaten huge meals i try not to you know
like if i go to a wedding and just down
everything and then come home I can't
sleep right away because I need a little
bit of time to digest this stuff comes
out cool but I just found out we almost
the same height I'm 63 and I'm 206 so I
work at a 2 or 6 it's more muscle / you
got more awesome days because you're
tall right so anyway okay so do you
think you sleep for you I know it's
important so do you see that like time
invested in sleep accessory like maybe
like you know a better but a mattress or
or you know sleep has all that kind of
stuff for you know the eye mask or
earplugs you feel like this is an
investment in you or is just extra o it
helps for sure I think um you know when
I go to a hotel for example my first
night sleep is always worse than the
second I just getting used to the bed in
a different environment we got one of
those memory foam mattresses that you
know conforms to your body my wife and I
fight over temperature in the room cuz I
like a colder than she does I've been
looking at this mat that like you can
put under your sheet that then cools you
down so I can have it cool down on my
side than on hers we'll see how that
goes you might go far enough um yeah and
the masks definitely helps and again if
I travel and I forget you know then then
I have terrible sleep the light is just
super sensitive for me for whatever
reason so making that investment
definitely helped yeah I heard that the
light actually the reason why you know
maybe for you even more is our body
whenever it feels light if it thinks
that the Sun is coming up there for it
starts to wake you up so if you have a
constant struggle between it's nighttime
so it's dark but you have some kind of
light coming up then your body is like
in between where is this I nanoscience I
know son so that might be you know one
of the reason our stars we closing out
like do you have like last advice for
entrepreneurs to get you know just
amazing sleep a couple of the things
that I do that might be a little weird
but that might help one is
I try to get my mind off of work it's
like if I'm lying in bed the thing that
will keep me up is work so I'll get up
and send that email but if I'm still
thinking about work then they'll be
super hard for me to get to sleep so
we'll often play a game like I'll get
out of bed and play like a game will
leave the legend or something and just
it transports me somewhere else where
I'm focusing on the game and then I
forget about what i was thinking about
and then i can go relax and sleep
afterwards so there's some other
distraction that you can do if you can't
get to sleep like you're lying in bed
you're tossing and turning like I'm I'm
so nervous and tomorrow Julia and I have
this this hangout and I want to do well
you know then doing something totally
different I find helps for me it's
league of legends but you could find
something for yourself I do an exercise
when I'm trying to relax two of its I
forget who taught me this it's a visual
exercise combined with breathing where I
just imagine like this might go it might
be trippy so we'll see but I imagined
you know I look look at my brain and
imagine like this full of is full of
crap it's full of people and ideas and
things that that happened to me that day
and then I'm like breathing in through
my nose like white air and then I
breathe it out and then I'm like
breathing out I'm breathing out Julian
you know I'm breathing out blue a long
scene tonight and breathing out reach
she kept TVs amazing video like I just
imagined it until until my brain is
empty because I breathed everything out
and just that process maybe it's just a
breathing that helps it's just I find
that that relaxes me and it helps me
fall asleep and then the last one I
don't do enough of that that somebody
had recommended to me was just go to bed
with gratitude I think about something
you're grateful for I guess it's just
because of like it de-stresses you a
little bit I don't do it enough but it
feels like it's a good idea you know
just thinking about I'm grateful for my
life my wife my health the you know the
Sun Toronto baseball dancing you know
whatever you're grateful for I think
might help put a stress
that you might be facing into contacts
and make you feel a little bit better
that is awesome I would love to get on
it you guys are on area what the what
struggle they are having this is a blast
to recognize yes in some questions um
rishi cup TV is writing in does it
affect your ability to work I don't know
what that was in reference to reach if
you want to maybe clarify if you want to
ask a question just to slash to you and
it'll pop up in our questions somebody
wrote in here Askia and slowed it up
here I really love your top 10 for
success videos what inspired you to
start producing them was it something
internal we draw inspiration from each
subject so not really related to sleep
but not happy to dive in on that a
little bit it was selfishly for me um I
guess relates to sleep in that like your
environment matters uh your environment
creaks who you are and for me I felt
like I wasn't getting enough challenge
in my environment I felt like the people
around me weren't challenging me enough
I wanted to do bigger and greater things
and I didn't have that in my environment
enough and so I thought hey if I can
surround myself with wisdom from people
who've done a lot more then I can
hopefully learn a little bit from them
to be the best version of myself so you
know I may not want to work as hard as
Mark Cuban but there's other things that
he does that I can learn from to make me
the best version of myself and so it was
really just trying to surround myself
with successful people from
entrepreneurs to actors to musicians to
politicians to you know people who've
achieved big things to help me do bigger
things myself so that's why i started
the top 10 was selfish and i shared it
and I'm glad that you guys appreciate it
and like it too but it really started as
like I wanted to get better and that was
the inspiration guys awesome shot you
see a question says I've been realizing
that maybe sometimes did you move it did
it go down oh let me put it let me pop
it up there you go okay so I've been
realizing that maybe sometimes I'm
working on
adrenaline and then crushing you guys
know anything about adrenal health and
have experienced this I think for me I
know I definitely have and I think this
time we talked about with like you know
you and flow where you're so high and
the energy is there and you want to work
on it and you feel it going you feel
like going to feel like going but at
some point you know slug that old the
old game NBA jam if you move that game
with your own fire and everything that
you shoot in that game is like you know
nothing but net nothing but net but at
some point the fire it runs out right it
needed to to understand that so I think
for me is like yes I do have it in and
once you go down and you want your
journal for me that's what I do it at
just journal so I let things out of my
head and I don't think about them
anymore I wind out if I mean I don't
know I don't know anything scientific
about adrenal health just my own
experiences I guess I think I think you
need the adrenaline as an entrepreneur
because you're creating something that
doesn't exist you don't have a boss
telling you what to do and in the joy
and excitement should be fuel for you to
create something amazing if you're not
excited about what you're doing you
don't have adrenaline then something's
probably wrong with your business you
might want to look at doing something
else and so sometimes I can last for
like an hour sometimes it can last the
whole day like when I was doing my book
it was just one straight adrenaline rush
for the day and I forgot to eat you know
that happens when I do these right like
I'm feeling energy now you know it's
great the the the Julian vibe will last
me for the next you know couple hours
i'll take it i think that i'm doing and
so it's doing things that doing things
that give you energy and trying to plan
those into your day i'm also a big fan
of trying to schedule similar things
together so like thursday is my public
face in a so i've already had two
meetings at starbucks today we're
talking to Julian I'm doing another one
at four o'clock I have a meeting later
on tonight all my meetings I try to
package together and I like I carry like
the next meeting that i have like Julian
space you guys right now or get
mean the vibe that I had from Derek and
end who are met with earlier and then
the guy go into next is going to take a
little bit of Julian to right so it's
like it all feeds similar energy it'd be
hard for me to jump from this to now
writing my book where I need to go like
introverted deep inside myself not not
be like the extrovert passionate guy but
go deeper in and so I find jumping
around too much between things messes me
up and so that's why i created my
schedule we talked a little bit about it
before I some people can do a while for
me I can't I need to I need to split
things up so I think adrenaline just
again I mean the obvious thing is take
care of your health but but you know I
also think it's okay to go crazy on
adrenaline like if you have that then
use it if you're if you're feeling
adrenaline rush then stay there as long
as you can and every now and then your
your your crash and I I like anticipate
that that's why I don't book anything in
the morning because if tonight goes nuts
and I'm just feeling a huge high like I
come home for the meeting I need to do
two hours of work because I'm on fire
then I can sleep in the next day and and
it's worth pushing off whatever I have
planned for that morning because what I
created the night before was gold so if
you're feeling those rushes then plan
plan it into your calendar to build
yourself back up so that you're not
making yourself sick love it alright
well guys I don't know if you have any
more questions for Evan or myself about
sleep but for me lasting is sleep
matters but that it doesn't matter don't
don't think that that that you need to
be upset because you you sleep because
you take a nap here and there if you if
you really work right I don't let people
did sleep more than they work or they
said like I need a break but they
haven't really worked you know that is
different right but if you truly work
hard and you push hard and and then you
feel like you need to take a break and
take a nap taken up because the quality
of work that you're going to produce
when you're tired is very low that the
amount of
time it takes you to produce quality of
work when you're tired is so much bigger
than the one that you have if you're not
tired of someone's that story of that
the two guys that I cutting a treat
right with the X and then one is like
he's hiding he's cutting his cutting
he's taking a break just you to sharpen
his acts right and the other one is
looking at him and saying what are you
doing man we have this that you know all
those trees and he's like yeah but you
know when i take a break because i feel
like my my ex is not sharp enough rice
the dead guys like no I'm gonna stop em
keep on going to keep on going to keep
on going and the other guys just waits
you know 30 mins to soda it comes back
with a really sharp axe and just get his
three down and in that keynote 20
minutes or so and then he has three or
four done and he goes back to his buddy
his buddies down this first street
because his ex wasn't sharpen anymore
right because he was tired so they flee
his hit when that is as strong anymore
so to me that's what constituted my must
like I'm tired I'm like dude I knew that
number one that they do this like
hitting but your access just not sharp
any more like you need to slow down
sharpen your axe and come back later to
I get it done sharpen your axe that's
the next t-shirt hahaha there we go cool
well thank you guys for joining Louis
thank you for giving me the 300 proud
sitting up to 99 for a while like all
right give me 300 celui I appreciate
that last little propagate to 300 Julian
for people watching where's the best
place to can find out about you and this
article that you're going to be posted
absolutely you can check it out at sleep
sumo calm so sleep sumo su mo calm and
you can always reach out to me if you
want to just email me at Julian the
French version so with an e Julian J dot
Marion ed gmail com awesome thank you
guys thank you Jillian have a great day
thanks guys bye